el Rey Carlos III será el primer monarca
en la historia británica de edad
avanzada en ser Coronado lo será a los
74 años la ceremonia se realizará en la
tradicional abadía de Westminster en el
centro de Londres donde se ha realizado
todas las coronaciones en los últimos
900 años y está promete ser un reflejo
de una sociedad mucho más moderna más
corta y que será transmitida en vivo y
en directo por la televisión de todo el
mundo y a través de las redes sociales
la de la Reina Isabel la última de la
que se tiene
récord por supuesto fue hace 69 años
esta duró tres horas y además tuvo
altísimos costos y muchos lujos lo que
se cree también es que la del Rey Carlos
III será un reflejo justamente por la
situación económica de crisis que
atraviesa el país Carlos tercero será
Coronado junto con su esposa arena con
suerte Camila Parker bowls Aunque
todavía no se conocen todos los detalles
de esta ceremonia